laurence je pense qu'elle doit être
extrêmement ému et triste de la nouvelle
bonsoir laurence merci d'être avec nous
en duplex a alors mal au dos je sais que
toi tu étais sur tf1 pendant des années
tu as tu as collaboré avec jean pierre
pernaut des années et des années durant
et c'est vrai que comme on disait ici
c'était juste un mec bien un jean pierre
pernaut c'était d'abord un médecin
c'était quelqu'un qui était très à
l'écouté des jeunes journalistes moi
j'ai démarré avec lui cyril en 97 ou 98
dont combien ça coûtera une toute petite
rubrique qui était une rubrique de
consommation et il m'a beaucoup aidé
c'était un prime time sur tf1 j'ai pas
si vous imaginez ces questions que ça
représentait pour une toute jeune
journaliste c'était des millions de
téléspectateurs et il a été formidable
il m'a aidé tout au long de ces années
de combien ça coûte et puis après quand
j'ai fait le 20 heures de tf1 qui était
encore une autre épreuve il a été là
solidaires présent attentionné et
c'était quelqu'un de bien il jouait pas
un personnage à l'antenne il était comme
cela en salle de conférence il était
comme ça dans les couloirs il était
authentique et sincère et c'est vrai que
on le dit souvent il ya énormément moi
ya de la jalousie dans ce métier comme
dans tous les métiers d'ailleurs mais il
sent pierre pernaut on a l'impression
voilà qu'ils voulaient vraiment aider
les autres il a mis beaucoup de gens à
l'antenne unités voilà il s'occupait pas
se préoccuper de ce que faisaient les
autres je n'ai jamais entendu dire du
mal d'un autre journaliste alors et
quand on lui disait qu'un autre
journaliste ali dit du mal de lui là
forcément il répondait avec souvent avec
sarcasme et et humour mais c'est vrai
que il était jean-pierre c'était
vraiment quelqu'un qui s'occupait juste
de son jt de sa carrière de sa famille
et regardez pas ce qui se passe ailleurs
il critiquait pas les autres mobilité
très au dessus de tout ça va s'arrêter
il était le journaliste le grand
journaliste vous avez rappelé qu'
évidemment il parlait beaucoup des
régions dans son journal me l'a
interviewé quatre grands présidents
c'était quelqu'un ski sur l'événement là
on est en pleine guerre en ukraine c'est
un événement qui l'aurait traité avec
toute une acuité une une perspective il
aurait su donner de l'épaisseur à cet
événement c'était d'abord un grand
journal il faut pas l'oublier et dans la
rue quand on marchait à côté de lui je
vous assure c'était incroyable il
faisait partie de la famille des
français ils étaient les gens le
prenaient dans les bras littéralement
c'est vrai c'est qu'on avait on avait
l'impression un moment que jean pierre
pernaut était au delà du journaliste au
delà de l'homme de télévision c'était
limite et autres un homme politique et
homme politique aimé de tous ça qui est
fou
un homme de télé lorsque vous avez
appris la nouvelle forcément je pense
que vous avez été très ému parce que
c'est vrai qu'en plus vous avez raconté
un peu votre histoire personnelle parce
que vous avez démarré avec lui on pense
forcément à sa famille ce soir qui nous
regarde d'ailleurs je crois puisque
nathalie m'envoyant un petit message en
atelier à ses enfants et lance si vous
avez un message à dire à sa famille qui
nous regardent ce soir ce serait qu' il
va vous manquer comme nous tous il vas y
vas me manquer il va nous manquer à nous
tous la france se perd un de ses membres
et mais surtout il va rester parce que
cette espèce de bienveillance et
empathie cette attention qui portait aux
autres mails seront présentes longtemps
encore et on va se souvenir longtemps de
jean pierre pernaut merci laurence
d'avoir été avec nous je vous embrasse
fort merci laurence merci merci dans ses
rares ils fêtaient avec l'ouverture